un travail colossal qui se poursuit ils
sont environ 1500 toujours à pied
d'oeuvre sur le terrain et l'opération
se complexifie
ce qui n'est pas le cas c'est que les
équipes s'attaquent maintenant en des
pannes qui touchent un moins grand
nombre de clients
secondaires c'est beaucoup c'est le même
effort mais peu de clients des fois ça
va être simple 10 clients
messieurs qui attendent toujours de
retrouver le courant sont à bout de
patience
d'hier on espérait surtout que là ça se
rapproche les rues autour en ont eu hier
c'était le riz au bout là c'est du
peut-être mais non c'est pas arrivé là
ça commence ça comme faut trouver des
plans B Québec a appelé en renfort les
épiciers habituellement fermés le
dimanche de Pâques les grands marchés
d'alimentation de 375 mètres carrés plus
pourront ouvrir toute la journée pour
ceux qui auront besoin d'aller acheter
des denrées mais difficile de répondre à
l'appel du gouvernement pour ceux qui se
relèvent aussi de la panne d'électricité
le stock du magasin dans le fond on a
deux remorques derrière une réfrigérés
une de congelés résultat impossible
d'accueillir les clients
ce qu'on a mis dans le réfrigérateur
c'est il y a du lait là dedans et du
fromage bon les dates tout ça qu'on est
comme pas vraiment prête
on pourrait tous aussi faire face à un
casse-tête au retour en classe mardi
l'offre alimentaire sera réduite dans
certaines écoles les cafétérias ont
aussi perdu de la nourriture et
l'approvisionnement est difficile
et Kim vous êtes ce soir devant une
résidence pour personnes âgées parce
qu'on apprend que certains
établissements ne sont toujours pas
rebranchés alors qu'ils sont pourtant
jugés prioritaires
c'est le cas du manoir Outremont Louis
où je me trouve actuellement où les
résidents ici sont plongés dans le noir
depuis mercredi en début d'après-midi si
vous voyez la lumière c'est parti il y a
depuis une génératrice qui a finalement
été mise en fonction mais en fait j'ai
parlé avec le fils d'une résidence de 93
ans qui me parlait d'une situation
vraiment très difficile dans les
derniers jours il y avait une petite
génératrice qui faisait en sorte que oui
les lumières de secours par exemple
pouvaient fonctionner mais dans les
appartements il faisait extrêmement
froid sa mère me disait-il devait se
couvrir de plusieurs couvertures porter
des vêtements supplémentaires et en plus
ils appartements Louis étaient dans le
noir complet alors si c'est des
situations aussi qui ont été rapportées
ailleurs par exemple à côté sur le lac
la résidence Marquis a dû être évacué
faute d'avoir de l'électricité
maintenant Louis ce que nous dit
Hydro-Québec c'est que toutes les RPA
tous les CHSLD qui sont effectivement
jugés prioritaires ont été rebranchés au
réseau électrique c'est toujours vrai
mais en fait ce qu'on se rend compte
c'est qu'il y avait finalement des
établissements qui n'étaient pas
officiellement inscrits sur les listes
comme étant des RPA ou des CHSLD qui
sont finalement passés sous le radar qui
n'avait pas encore été rebranché
Hydro-Québec qui se veut quand même
rassurance en disant que l'objectif le
rebrancher tous les abonnés va vraiment
montrer si bien que ces établissements
qui ne sont pas encore rebranchés
devraient l'aide au cours des prochaines
heures ça pose maintenant plusieurs
questions faudra sans doute en discuter
de tout ça collectivement comment
s'assurer qu'une telle situation ne se
reproduise plus ce sera certainement des
choses qu'il faudra clarifier dans le
futur dit-on et après plusieurs jours
comme ça et là les patients montrent
chez les derniers sinistrés et donc
Québec lance un appel au calme après des
incidents là qui sont survenus
parce que dans certains arrondissements
Montréal il y a eu des situations assez
déplorables ou des employés
d'Hydro-Québec ont été intactivés
Hydro-Québec qui tient à dire Louis que
ce sont vraiment des situations isolées
la plupart des gens sont très
encourageants et puis encourage vraiment
les équipes qui sont toujours à pied
d'oeuvre sur le terrain mais
effectivement aujourd'hui on a tenu à
l'ancien appel au calme pour rappeler
que tout le monde finalement mais la
main à la porte là pour tenter de
résoudre ce problème qui me permettent à
Montréal merci beaucoup
je vous en prie